in this video I'll be talking about a
remarkable alternative theory or
interpretation of quantum mechanics
pilot-wave theory
aka de brug bond theory aka bohmian
mechanics there are people who think
that this theory has been disproved or
discredited but more recently there are
also people who think that bone
mechanics explains everything quantum
mechanics does without any of the
quantum witness both of these positions
are wrong so I thought it was time for
me to make a new video clarifying all
this since my old videos on this are now
three years old so what is bohmian
mechanics to answer that I better
quickly explain what quantum mechanics
is 100 or more years ago physicists was
finally able to do experiments on really
small things like atoms and though that
was cool they weren't really expecting
to be surprised Newton's laws and the
rest of physics as they knew it should
apply just as well to galaxies as
electrons but that's not what they found
take for example double slit experiment
when you shoot things one at a time
through two doors you'd expect that if
it makes it through that it will go
through one of those doors and end up
somewhere behind it so you eventually
get two lumps they decided to do this
simple experiment with really small
things like atoms you shoot them one at
a time
but you can't actually see them going in
their paths so you can't see which door
they went through but you'd expect them
to do the same thing essentially as
before and end up in the same two lumps
only they don't they end up in this
weird pattern this will scratch their
heads then they tried the same thing
again but this time they closed one of
the doors randomly now the particle has
to be going through just one door and so
it has to just land somewhere behind
that door and there right the final
pattern is what they expected in the
first place but then they tried it again
with both doors open at once just to
check and it was the same strange
pattern so they scratched their
collective heads again and came up with
an idea they proposed Newton was wrong
after all
actually what
really happens is when an object has
more than one option available to it and
no one is checking which it is done it
does all of them at once this is called
a quantum superposition they gave it
this fancy name because they didn't
really know what they meant by doing all
possible things at once now this does
sound totally crazy but look they said
it can explain the double slit
experiment see the atom doesn't just go
through one door or the other it goes
through both then it's able to interfere
with itself and that gives the strange
pattern when there's only one door open
it is an inner superposition and so it
can't interfere with itself and so it
does the usual thing and so you get back
to the normal pattern this quantum
superposition thing got applied to many
many many more experiments and it always
made the right prediction and so even
though quantum mechanics is crazy we're
all forced to accept it by experimental
facts at least that's the conventional
wisdom then came bohmian mechanics the
aim of this theory is to explain all the
same experimental data as quantum
mechanics can but without superposition
in fact you can prove that bohmian
mechanics produces exactly the same
results as quantum mechanics for all
possible experiments but the objects in
this theory are always in one place and
they have one speed how is that possible
let's look at the double slit experiment
to understand in bohmian mechanics the
particle must have a path from its start
through one of the slits to the back
wall since the particle is in just one
spot at each time in contrast in quantum
mechanics the particle takes every
possible path the first thing that this
theory needs to explain is if your
particles all start in one place and
they follow a predetermined path why
don't they all end up in exactly the
same spot bohmian mechanics explains
this by saying you don't actually know
exactly where the particles started out
this first particle might have been just
left of where the other particle was
which meant that they end
up in different places it's just because
you didn't know exactly where it started
that you don't know where I'll end up
now this is the exact same as in the non
quantum case that we looked at so that
sounds very reasonable but a fancy way
to put this is that the initial position
is a hidden variable since it's a
variable that you don't know it's hidden
making bohmian mechanics a hidden
variable theory you'll hear the term
hidden variable used disparagingly all
the time by people so I thought I'd
introduce it to you so you see that it's
not necessarily a bad thing for a theory
to have hidden variables anyway this is
the important part
so to check you're paying attention let
me ask you a question
suppose that in the situation that one
door was closed this is the path that
this particle would take according to
bohmian mechanics if I open the other
door now will that path change or not
seriously pause the video now and think
about the answer
well let's see what would happen if the
past didn't change then all objects that
went through this door would end up sort
of here and similarly for objects going
through the other door you end up with
the wrong prediction then but I told you
bohmian mechanics always gets it right
so what really happens is the particles
path does change when the other door is
open even though it's not going to go
through it that means that if that door
is open it feels a force pushing it into
some weird wonky paths like this in fact
here's a simulation of a bunch of paths
that particles starting in slightly
different positions take and you can see
where they end up really does exactly
reproduce the interference pattern so
here's the key takeaway point from that
there still is quantum weirdness in
bohmian mechanics it's just a bit hidden
in standard quantum mechanics a particle
is in a superposition of all possible
places but in bohmian mechanics the
particle is in one place but it's aware
of and affected by all the other
possible places it could be just to be
clear this is not a typical feature of a
classical theory of physics but bohmian
mechanics has one really awesome
advantage over standard quantum
mechanics it doesn't have the
measurement problem the measurement
problem is arguably the biggest
conceptual difficulty of quantum
mechanics so let me explain that in the
double slit experiment imagine if you
put two little detectors on the doors
that flush every time a particle goes
through then you could find out which
door the particle went through but then
you look at the pattern and you see that
it's not the interference one anymore
this is explained in ordinary quantum
mechanics by saying that when you
measure a particle that's in a
superposition the superposition
collapses to doing just one thing but
why why do quantum particles get shy
like that bond proposed the solution to
this inside of bony mechanics called
decoherence it's basically the idea that
when you measure something what you're
really doing is getting your measurement
device to interact
with it and that interaction makes it
look like there's been this collapse I
won't go into this much here because
decoherence deserves its own video not
just on how it relates to bohmian
mechanics but also how it relates to
other interpretations like many worlds
but now let's look at a common criticism
of bohmian mechanics you'll hear people
harp on about how Bell's Theorem proves
that no hidden variable Theory can give
the same results as quantum mechanics
this is clearly rubbish because bohmian
mechanics exists and predicts everything
quantum mechanics does and is a hidden
variable theory you know who else used
to get frustrated by people
misinterpreting Bell's Theorem john bell
he was a huge fan of Bhogi mechanics and
wrote lots of things about it for
example this quote about bones
explanation of the double slit
experiment he didn't misunderstand his
own theorem what Bell's Theorem actually
says is that any theory that reproduces
the results of quantum mechanics so for
example quantum mechanics itself and
bohmian mechanics has to be non-local
something is non-local when you have one
thing over here affecting another thing
over there instantly
so yes quantum mechanics and bohmian
mechanics are non-local and furthermore
the situation's they're non-local in are
the same basically EPR like experiments
where there's a person on each of the
two sides of the universe and what one
of them does to their particle instantly
affects the other's particle this is a
point I think that people get confused
about you might have seen Veritas Ian's
beautiful video on how you can reproduce
the effect of pilot-wave theory by using
a water phenomena called walking
droplets if you haven't watched that
then do it's absolutely mesmerizing
these walking droplets are completely
classical in fact in the video Derek
makes them at home and so you might be
tempted to conclude that pilot-wave
theory is totally classical since it can
be mimicked classically but can all of
pilot-wave theory be mimicked by these
water
experiments actually it's only
experiments where there isn't entangled
particles that can be mimicked this way
because when there are entangled
particles in pilot-wave theory they
affect each other's movements no matter
how far away they are from each other
but classical systems can't have these
non-local effects and so they can't
produce the right results that's why
these water experiments can reproduce
all kinds of quantum phenomena like the
double slit experiment or tunneling or
harmonic potentials but could never
reproduce the Bell experiment it's
impressive how much bromium mechanics
can explain classically but it still has
very non classical parts and that's
important to remember to wrap up there
are plenty of big pros but also a fair
number of cons for anyone considering
taking bohmian mechanics as their
interpretation of quantum mechanics but
enough being impartial you might be
wondering do I believe in bohmian
mechanics no I don't but I don't believe
any interpretation of quantum mechanics
since there are several that are
consistent with the facts at the moment
but do I like bohmian mechanics yes and
no no because I worry about how natural
the mass of that theory really is but
yes because on some level it's so much
more intuitive and it answers the
measurement problem but putting aside
how plausible I find the theory itself
the thing I love most about bohmian
mechanics aka pilot-wave theory is that
it shows us that there is still plenty
of room for debate on what quantum
mechanics actually means that even
something as seemingly fundamental as
quantum superposition can be questioned
we need to keep investigating and asking
questions about the interpretation of
quantum mechanics as john bell put it
Boehm has shown us the way